الأسبوع الرابع من الكفاح الجديد في أوكرانيا
ضد البرد والظلام
بطانية انقطاع التيار الكهربائي في كييف
الليل مخيف ونحن ندخل هذا
المجمع السكني الشاهق لنرى
كيف يتعامل السكان مع
الهجمات الروسية المستمرة على البنية التحتية الرئيسية
حتى الطابق الثاني عشر.  ضوء في
بئر الدرج ولكن كاميراتنا ولا يوجد
مصعد تقابلنا يوليا مندل وهي
تتعرج على عكازين والقدم التي
كسرت بسبب التعثر على الدرج في
الليلة الأولى من انقطاع التيار الكهربائي ، أليس كذلك ،
إنها صحفية وسكرتيرة صحفية سابقة
للرئيس زيلينسكي
سنقوم معًا بزيارة جارتها ناتاليا
مع ابنتها لينا البالغة من العمر 18 شهرًا وهي
واحدة فقط من جيل كامل من
أطفال كييف الذين أصيبوا بصدمة بسبب الحرب ، خاصة
مع صفارات الإنذار المستمرة من الغارات الجوية ، هل
تشعر بالتوتر وكأنها
تشير إلى النافذة حتى تعرف
ذلك  حدث خطأ
ما ، وهما يتعافيان من
محنة استمرت ساعتين محاصرين في
المصعد الصغير عندما انقطعت الكهرباء
الآن في جميع أنحاء كييف  يضع السكان
صناديق رعاية صغيرة بالداخل مع
وجبات خفيفة من الماء وأدوية مضادة للقلق
بحلول الوقت الذي جلسنا فيه للتحدث عن
القوة التي ظهرت مرة أخرى بعد تسع
ساعات في هذا اليوم ، هل تشعر
بالإحباط هل تشعر أنك بخير ، حسنًا
، لقد حان الوقت بالفعل
للاستسلام والتفاوض بأي حال من الأحوال أه انظر
لقد مررنا بمصاعب
التسعينيات ولم يكن لدينا تسخين مياه خفيف
وكل شيء لساعات
وساعات كل يوم وكان ذلك وقتها
يائسًا لأننا لم نكن نعلم
أنه يتعلق بالفقر  الآن يتعلق الأمر بالحرب
ونعلم أننا يجب أن نفوز بالفوز في هذه
المرحلة من الحرب يأتي بأسلحة مثل
هذه لشحن الهواتف وأي
معدات طوارئ أخرى ، إنه بنك طاقة
بدونه ليس لديك أي
اتصال وهو الأهم
الآن  لمعرفة أن أقاربك
بخير ، يخبروننا أن المولدات قد نفدت كلها تقريبًا
وباهظة الثمن الآن بالإضافة
إلى مشاعل الشموع والمصابيح الأمامية
قامت ناتاليا بضبط الضوء من زجاجة مياه
وهي  iPhone في
وسط المدينة ، إنه أمر مزعج بالنسبة للشركات أيضًا ،
يعمل كل صالون تجميل على
مجففات الشعر لهذا الانفجار وبالطبع
الماء لغسل الشامبو
وصبغة Olena تأخذ فرصها اليوم
بعد أن ننتهي من صبغها ، قد أضطر
إلى العودة إلى المنزل لتجفيفها ولكن  حسنًا ،
هناك طابق واحد فقط به طاقة
والأخرى مظلمة
قبل الحرب ، كان لدى Hair House 150
عميلًا في اليوم ، أصبح الآن أكثر من 50 عميلًا
وخسر الصالون 60 في المائة من
إيراداته ،
ولكن كما أخبرني ديميتري المدير التجاري ،
فقد ظلوا هادئين و  نواصل ،
نعتقد أنه يجب علينا العمل حتى بدون
ضوء حتى بدون كهرباء ، يجب أن
نساعد جيشنا ، يجب أن نساعد
شعبنا وسنقوم بعملنا حتى النهاية
ونعتقد أنه عاجلاً أم آجلاً
سيأتي الضوء مثل العديد من المدنيين
يقولون  تحمل هذه المصاعب على
الجبهة الداخلية هو جزء من مجهودهم الحربي
لدعم قواتهم على الخطوط الأمامية
الذين يقاتلون من أجل إبقاء أوكرانيا
مستقلة وتقاتل من أجل وطنهم.
كيث